[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
la zac de coeur de ville à cheval entre
les communes d'orsay et de saclay est
situé entre le quartier de l'école
polytechnique à palaiseau et de quartier
de moulins entre juifs et aux recettes
nous sommes ici dans la partie sud du
quartier de cordes ville de terrains sur
lesquels nous sommes situés étaient
communément appelée la triche thales en
effet l'entreprise thalès il y avait
installé des bureaux et de laboratoires
même le château que nous voyons derrière
nous avait été transformée en espace de
travail pour l'entreprise
aujourd'hui de désamiantage et la
démolition des bâtiments de bureaux est
achevé et il a été décidé d'utiliser
cette friche dans le cadre du projet
européen
le terrain est à présent après
accueillir de nouveaux usages
le projet porté par le pea par isaac et
consiste à valoriser l'emplacement
privilégié de ce site en connexion
directe avec la vallée au travail du
coteau boisé sur la partie ouest de la
friche un grand parc sera aménagé il
aura vocation à être utilisé par tous
les usagers du plateau et les habitants
de la vallée à l'est du château un
quartier de logements et d'équipements
sera créé il bénéficiera de vue
privilégiée sur les châteaux le coteau
et la vallée
pour les dossiers réglementaires de la
zac de corneville le diagnostic
environnemental a identifié plusieurs
enjeux écologiques notamment la présence
d'espèces patrimoniales et d'habitat
intéressant pour la biodiversité
le site est particulièrement intéressant
pour les chiroptères les chauves-souris
neuf espèces ont été identifiées sur
l'intégralité du site notamment au
niveau des caves les dépendances du
château ccap seront conservés et
notamment les entrées seront aménagés
pour mettre chiroptères de continuer à
les fréquenter et empêché l'accès du
public
une attention particulière sera portée à
l'éclairage nocturne notamment pour
réduire son impact sur ces espèces la
châtaigneraie un site remarquable
notamment par la présence de gros arbres
anciens avec de nombreuses qualités
ses qualités sont utilisés par beaucoup
d'espèces notamment des oiseaux et les
chiroptères et dans le cadre du projet
d'aménagement un espace public sera créé
ici et la plupart des arbres seront
conservés en les mettant à distance des
principaux cheminement
le mur d'enceinte domaine de corbier et
en meulière il fait environ 600 mètres
de long et c'est un habitat favorable
pour le lézard des murailles une espèce
protégée
également présente sur le site et dans
le cadre du projet d'aménagement
plusieurs passages seront créés au sein
de ce mur et les parties qui seront
détruites seront reconstitués juste à
côté
enfin la renaturation d'une grande
partie de la friche en parc public
permettra d'améliorer la biodiversité du
secteur grâce à l'augmentation d'environ
700 arbres
[Musique]